what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are back to watch a
movie that I I've been dying to watch
this Tara I it's been on the top of my
list for months and when you said you
hadn't seen it I said come over tomorrow
yeah here we are finally going to watch
this Freaky Friday it's weird that I
have not seen this because I've heard a
lot about it and then I saw the article
come out that they're going to put out
another one with the same cast I'm
excited guys you know what to do leave a
like leave a like if you enjoyed this
video and ring that
follow Tara Erickson on her YouTube
channel where she does reactions as well
over there thank you to all who have
followed us on our patreon page becoming
super sexy rejects over there we do full
length Reaction watch Songs We sync it
with your own copy of Freaky Friday you
can watch the whole thing with us on Cut
and we cover plenty of things over there
exclusively with the reaction highlights
and watch along is included Tara you
already get freaky I'm ready to get free
I burped during that sentence so that
means I'm extra ready to get freaky or
not a woman my body is ready my mind is
ready the groups are ready let's do this
let's do it
day and night it's only right what an
interesting choice
like yeah this is a Vibe right here
happy together
six o'clock time it's too early that's
when the switch should happen
[Music]
I like to switch your music to represent
the generations
[Music]
get acquainted with the routine so I'm
just gonna get a little
end of discussion feet down
you you women
oh kill me Anna what he's in this Chad
Michael Murray yes I think he's gonna
talk to you
that's older he was so skinny hello he's
in high school you pervert sorry he's
still cute when I want a leprechaun ice
sculpture not even Irish
could you hold on a second
whoa you should be looking at the road
we almost hit that pedestrian and really
somebody's gonna die here
oh that's embarrassing a lot of
embarrassing moments up top here
f
sweet choker though
[Music]
oh
creepy teacher you completely missed the
point of the book it's a blatant attack
on totalitarianism about a rigid Society
dominated by one all-powerful ego
tripping dictator my grade is final
except he had hair
oh he's your teacher girl and up
you have to wear a clipboard that says
detention on it you're counting the
minutes aren't you no how many minutes
are left 54.
all right this morning was good
but then I got up
that sounds like my everyday
you know I'm surprisingly good at
volleyball
anyway
oh my God hit her in the head yeah come
on now Clover her
oh nice
I'm gushing
turkey meatloaf
yes Elizabeth I'll be at the appointment
tomorrow and Elizabeth remember you are
a smart strong beautiful independent
woman and you don't need a man to
complete you
bye
Goodbye
Oh my God
thank you
a guitar pick are they gonna Vibe over
music see you in a band
sorta what do you mean sorta well you
know we're still stuck in our garage
face
you go to his bedroom
so what do you say
you want to ride for sure there you go
you can wear my extra helmet
a Ducati how does he afford that he's in
high school you like the hives they're
awesome
oh look I've got this important I was
thinking maybe if you wanted to we could
get together
block
oh and he's gone he's just like that so
dreamy off into the sunset yeah
it's an original song sounds like it
oh sweetheart
um all right ready I kind of deserved it
he was playing drums on her guitar if
she divorced her as the dad dead
great question what
what I thought I'd ask the author
damn she really learned how to play
guitar I don't know I don't think that's
her
there's no way oh that is
that is mean
rude come on Mom let us Rock one of the
Bands dropped out of the wangle Tango
auditions and we are the first alternate
shut up oh no Jamie Lee you better not
sabotage get it together
that's my mom's rehearsal dinner
Anna come on
come on so is her mom's rehearsal yeah
she getting married y'all we're screwed
yep
yeah
[Music]
you know her mom put so much attention
into helping her patients but is
neglecting her family's emotional needs
emotional well-being
with Stacy Hank house going to end never
[Music]
you've got an F in English today well Mr
Bates is out to get me you know he just
looks for ways to torture me like today
the One Time Jake even spoke to me he
totally is Jake
uh oh he's just this really amazing guy
mom where'd you meet him
detention but
no outside of detention
oh is it like a fortune cookie situation
uh
oh that would be awesome
try and do better mom I'll really really
try all right what do you want because
this really important audition that
we're having tomorrow night that we
could never have again at the House of
Blues Anna I need to talk to you right I
think I'm gonna pass on that now why are
you getting so serious let's talk about
it I really want to understand I really
do want to understand Anna
oh mama stay out of it please no love it
they're interfering they're meddling
Anna high school is not that hard you
couldn't last one day in my high school
challenge accepted I felt it you think
my life is perfect oh I know your life
is perfect your perfect job perfect
boyfriend perfect
you're about to learn so much you
[Music]
know you're all right
okay thank you this is gonna be begging
to get back to Stacy in volleyball after
one minute in her mom's life
Journey soon begin it's prize reflected
in another's eyes and what you see is
what you lack will change you back
[Music]
they didn't have to eat it whoa honey
yeah oh
everyone's dead
yeah okay an earthquake oh an earthquake
no there was no earthquake you didn't
feel it
no
I don't think so it was an emotional
metaphor interesting
spooky so the Chinese woman's the
villain
how does that keep going that's cool
[Music]
uh so the switch must have happened
already let the games begin breaking act
two
I better get up
I'd better
why am I in Anna's room
[Music]
Hannah come here quick what mom's dead
I'm dead I'm dead
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
look I think something's happened to us
what are you
oh my god this is my mother that's so
good
clone free
look at me I know we seem to be
incredible
[Laughter]
I want my body back and I don't want
mine my weddings tomorrow
I carry Ryan ew
you're in my body and I'm in your body
why don't we like adult okay you go over
there and I go over here
go
oh
ouch I was just teaching Mom some new
dance moves what do you want Punk
[Music]
honey
did them okay
I'll take it
sweetheart
what are you doing here I thought you
said you needed a ride to work Mom I
guess you better hurry up
go to work I will go to school and you
will stay right
what Evan Evan who's Evan oh my neediest
patient I've been seeing him every day
for the past three years that's not
healthy I mean what am I supposed to say
to the freak nothing you are in no way
to give anyone any advice that would be
unethical just listen attentively not
occasionally you really want us to be
Each Other Well we will get to this
morning as each other and then we will
go back to the restaurant at lunch and
get switched back now go get dressed
they're really good at this Switcheroo
yeah it's great
you pierced your navel
yeah I meant to talk to you about that
when did you do this at Maddie's
cousin's sweet 16 .
what is she
what is she doing I don't know why you
never wear these they're so cute what if
you're selling Bible oh my God
what's up
so good while I'm apologizing let me
just say to the whole car how truly poor
I am for being such an insane control
freak all the time
I'm the one who should be apologizing
for my flagrant disregard for anyone's
feelings but my own
yeah kiss him great we're getting
married isn't it even though my husband
died how quickly I've been able to get
over it just pull up here oh
sick burn you manage alien Ryan in my
body that'd be nice but don't kiss him
oh Mom I just had breakfast that's
disgusting
she's great at this
[Music]
that is the last thing I'm going to give
him just look at him you don't even know
him I know he's too old for you oh my
God he's coming over here say hi back
now say hi back I'm gonna break with
Ryan
this is my mother Dr Coleman
hi
oh my goodness
it's a great bike
not like I've ever been on it I'm not
allowed
I mean I'm allowed because I'm old
I gotta go
[Music]
[Laughter]
I've got the highs for you had enough
you know but they're coming to town next
week I was wondering if maybe you wanted
that's a really nice thought and I'm
sure with a haircut you'd look quite
presentable
you truth be told you're way too old for
me you're sabotaging this
[Music]
he's so cute and he brought your CD
Hi how are you wonderful
[Music]
oh I hate Stacy oh nice stunt so we saw
you tell me what would Jake give us the
dirty detail excuse me
I don't believe in physical contact with
the opposite sex
need a ride home you're gonna pick up
the Volvo most definitely be picking up
the Volvo huh yeah
[Music]
shopping spree yeah
ah
[Music]
tell me other things I wanna hear
whoa oh she's going all oh my goodness
full-on makeover
[Music]
oh
nice oh my goodness
I have the rehearsal dinner you look
fantastic
are you canceling the session Kevin Evan
Evan F
M oh so you don't answer your phone I
told you I wouldn't be able to call you
on your honeymoon but you lied to me
you're a liar I'll get it
my God it's insufferable
a thousand dollars for what
what kind of caterer are you it's just
sting
so Ethan Evan Evan I knew that
it's getting work done with all that
phone ringing yeah and she's not gonna
be any food at the wedding I've seen him
that's good
like every day in this torture chamber
oh my god did Bates have a crush on the
mom what are the central conflicts in
Hamlet well political of course because
Claudius deserved his father's Throne
edible because of the undercurrents with
his mother
nice is he really seeing his father's
ghost or is he simply mad that is
seriously
overreaching what a dick I hate him
depressed you know then I got all right
anyway
he's not gonna look for people who are
looking to go to betterhealth.com
Rejects
I'm concerned doctor that she and this
boy might be you know stop
stop nothing is going on between her and
the sky because if there was she
wouldn't be writing about it in her
diary she'd be out there doing it hmm
and he probably even flirted with her a
little bit but he secretly likes your
daughter he just hasn't made his move
yet because that wouldn't be cool so now
her best friend is acting like some
psycho freak
interesting I never would have thought
about it that way cool guess we're done
oh God they're going to be financially
broke Beats Elton Bates Griffith High
School how do you know that you asked me
I mean my mom did
this is taking it out on her daughter
aren't you aren't you I don't know what
you're talking about come on it was a
high school dance I mean you've got to
let it go and move on man I'm sure the
school board would love to hear about
your pathetic Vendetta against an
innocent student yeah
yeah well I don't think Elton Bates will
be giving me much trouble anymore it's
so weird about your mom oh yeah what did
she say that one
that's great
well it is her rehearsal dinner I mean
don't you think that's rather important
too don't give us this energy is totally
ruining our lives
if it were any other night but tonight
whatever Anna
I don't think the rehearsal dinner is a
good idea considering the current plight
you're in
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa uh get out of the car I'm driving
oh my god what have you done to me do
you like it
right now
[Music]
you cannot eat fast food why not because
it will go down your throat and drop
instantly to my thighs this food will
make you blow up like a balloon but it
will do nothing whatsoever to me oh Mom
now there's long-term effects
oh God this is good Mom that's not fair
my first French fry in eight years eight
years she is not living
[Music]
whoa when we woke up this morning we
weren't ourselves yeah
oh mama oh this has happened before
what did she say oh she's crazy
when the fortune come true
how about 10 off cater no but
no Pepe told you we have a caterer
actually mom there's something I forgot
to tell you good idea how about I do
you have to be at Harry School in 15
minutes
mom yeah how different she walks he is a
sweet boy
but he's having a little trouble with
bullies
so
that's character building
you know he's very good in English I um
I had the class write an essay on who
they admire most and he wrote a
wonderful paper about your daughter wow
what
that's so sweet she showed me the paper
you wrote about Anna you saw that little
before I like her
because we have too much fun fighting
that is so touchy I love that why does
this have to be world war three I mean
all those years of trick-or-treating and
sleepovers sit with me
communication that's all it takes oh God
look at you you again redress you're
sexy losing sore I don't see anything I
don't know
oh my gosh that was amazing still got
your eyes
oh my goodness she's gonna be on a show
you're on the Dottie Robertson show
because we're ready for you now Dr
Coleman I know you get nervous but
you're gonna be great oh no you want to
prepare for something like this you
don't surprise someone with a television
appearance yeah
[Music]
foreign
she's copying my test
[Music]
Stacy gets attention I hope Stacy gets
beheaded
loved your book I actually read this one
I actually read this one now what got
you
what you did in the physical and
intellectual exhaustion that
Sor let's say no longer 20.
it's an Essence like senile old people
got it got it
hey
that's cruel but do it Stacy's so mean
show your stand-up guy Chad Michael she
had her chance
do you want to know
why adults are so tired all the time
because they spend all their time
obsessing about these stupid lame things
they don't really have to do oh like a
cookie have you never heard of takeout
let's don't say we did
quality time
it's called the reading between the
lines oh my God
let's just say this cute guy asks you
out what are you gonna do
oh
Hurry Up This Guy's hot water
out God your mom's cool
[Applause]
[Music]
that's great
I mean I saw what you did to Stacy's
test I think you're right you're too
young for me
stand up guy leaving her in the dust
that guy doesn't exist can I have a quad
shot caramel latte
I work here
hey you know I caught the show and you
were you're great oh my God he's gonna
beat her oh yes you like The Vines I got
the bootlegs shot
that kid is so cute
oh my gosh they're falling in love you
should be working yeah what are you
doing just sitting down
[Music]
uh this is so awkward I feel like I know
you
go really I just please
oh my gosh
okay okay
no
[Music]
bad situation what you were doing on the
eve of our wedding
straddling some guy on the back of a big
black Harley
the Ducati the Ducati
my mom wouldn't let me go out with him
so I just had to beg her to check him
out for me and she did
he's a very together young man and
she approves
really
[Laughter]
I know
I must confess I still believe that is
so awkward I know it's unconventional
okay and I know nothing can happen I'm
not
stupid I just you're behaving pretty
stupid I want to be able to talk to her
do not come near my mother or her fiance
do you understand man I don't understand
anything oh you really need to find
someone your own age
that's awkward that guy's a creep very
awkward take that guy it's just creepy
he's obsessed let's try to be selfless
give me your hands
okay I'm being selfless are you being
selfless yeah I'm being selfless
dude I'm really sorry but couldn't we
just borrow Anna for like 20 minutes
we'd never ask you or like anybody for
anything ever again I am appalled at you
too I clearly said go
oh nice guy what are you still doing
here go right now thank you thank you so
much no no no
she's gonna be terrible the role of
insensitive stepfather who couldn't care
lesser thinks it's a stupid rock band or
any of the Preposterous things you just
said I'm not that guy Tess and if that's
who you think I am then this is never
going to work wow good for you I never
pushed Anna because I want her to like
me on her own terms in her own way you
should be over there oh go I can hold
down the fort here for 20 minutes
that's so sweet should have gave him a
big kiss on the lips
serious fantasy
you like me at all you will just leave
me alone
please no Creep from right here in Los
Angeles let's give it up for pink slip
oh my god get on the stage mom yeah come
on now
[Music]
oh God
yeah at least Fake It come on now
[Music]
oh God
this is humiliating just go out there
and
just go act like kids
are you gonna play it backstage yeah I
think so she better hey
[Music]
stressing me out
[Applause]
thank God
I'm in love with you now yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
that one part of the solo saved this
whole performance
selfless off switch
that quickly he changes his mind to Anna
Gotta Get A Life buddy yeah like what
are you doing don't you have like
parties to go to I need you to Tell Ryan
that you need to postpone the wedding I
can see you're not ready for this and I
can wait I guess that I was just so
happy I wasn't thinking about what's
best for you and Harry
just please let him know that I love him
and be as kind as you possibly can for
me that audition got her this job not
the years of worse she already had good
job
Bingo baby now I know how Anna feels and
and what she feels is that no one could
ever take the place of her dad
somebody could
be part of a new family
its own kind of cool new
little unit
that for some special as Ryan that we
would all just make a little room
[Music]
whoa now they all felt it
full shot
love it
[Music]
what the hell just happened trust you
you don't want to know
a Chinese woman done good done good
Chinese woman and it's Catering by them
for everything
I love you I love you too
do you think we could just rewind this
whole thing and start again
he has like the tiniest little scruff
right here
both you and your mom know what it's
like to kiss this guy awkward
you go ask her then you'll fart Hey now
wait a minute wait if I was your age oh
okay
well yes I don't mind
no
[Music]
okay yay
oh damn she gets to perform at the
wedding that's what I'm talking about
people surprise a guy directed it only
women can direct other women right
I know that was a really fun movie super
fun I had a great time the the kid thing
was weird I forget what his name is I'm
just gonna call him Chad Michael that
part is weird but the rest of it is
great super fun they did such a good job
playing each other
like so funny to see Jamie Lee Curtis
play
Lindsay loh I think I vice versa I I
think I because movie's been out for a
long time
um
I think the one one of the things I
heard about it was that
when they did this movie they had each
other like record how they would do the
lines oh and they just did them that way
to take some inspiration from how they
might ah I don't know if I'm making that
up that's great and very helpful
um yeah I if I if that is true uh you
commented in the comment boxes I'm
pretty sure that is something I heard
that they actually did for it smart
um but yeah I thought they did an
excellent job I know this is because you
know like uh the body swap comedy kind
of or horror movies The Body Shop comedy
movies uh is a really fun genre but a
lot of times they can't really go well
but let's pull it off right yeah yeah
they kind of just go for like
bits like raunchy bits or something like
that
um I don't know if raunchy is the right
word but they usually just go for bits
but here they really had a they had a
really solid setup at the beginning of
really getting you to understand who
they are in act one it's not about when
the switch route did happen you you
could uh feel the the tension of the
situations they'd be thrusted into yeah
throughout the journey and it's had a
really good heart throughout it was like
amazing performances I agree the heart
in it like when
um
oh when the the kid shows his paper his
paper is about his sister and then when
Jamie comes out and is like Oh I thought
that was just so sweet don't tell her I
like her that's such a sweet moment just
to set up like the kid it's not like he
was forgotten about but their
relationship was covered between him and
his sister and then
um obviously at the end when she's like
crying and I'm gonna do this selfless
thing for you it's it's probably tears
yeah I teared up too yeah that was
really touching super so sweet and for
their ability to switch in and out of
care to play both characters and really
feel both the emotions I was like yeah
that is an impressive it's an impressive
like crying scene to pull off that I was
like dang like yeah both of them I mean
obviously outstanding actors in their
own right but like in this was
I've never really have you seen The
Parent Trap I've never seen The Parent
Trap either
I might not have I'm looking at her face
going like have I seen this movie I'm
gonna cover Lindsay Lohan's career
backwards yes now let's see her when she
was like five see how she did that I
mean she's awesome I don't know if I've
seen The Parent Trap honestly yeah what
I remember would that be a movie or it's
like I've definitely seen The Parent
Trap uh would that be one of those
movies because right now I'm like I
don't think I saw it
1998. I would you would you would have
been at least 30 32 at the time yeah
around there so surround that around
that age yeah
yeah absolutely
what would be the sequel to this though
would it be them switching I feel like
they would just be aren't they just I
mean are they just gonna like redo it
yeah what would be the purpose of them
redoing it
because this is kind of like a perfect
film in a lot of ways oh other than some
creepy undertones that they got that
they got older and they lost touch with
each other as as maybe mom and daughter
and daughter gets distracted with life
and I'm married now and I have kids and
mom is still married with husband and
whatever and they've grown apart and now
they must intervene again to be like
mother and daughter have to come back to
be like mother and daughter again like
closer that's how I would play it so
it's not the same movie it's still the
same actors are going to use right yeah
so like that would be a good way like
they've lost touch and so it has to
happen for them to like come back
together or it could be a commentary on
today's climate when it comes to the
discourse that some people have around
the trans community and seeing like how
topical they can make it that's true
meaning like
you know switching by right
I just wanted this video to take a very
different direction Gregory
how far we can push a subject
I'm like I feel like in the movie
they're both female
identifying females so I was like no
they might they might just be in the
movie but it might focused on different
characters okay all right well there he
had his take I had mine mine I want it
to be political the next one I wanted
pickles
commentary and the serious consequences
yeah okay yeah life or death Stakes yeah
I mean I think you can make this like a
dark psychological Thriller they always
make these body swap movies like
comedies and I think you could make this
one like a thriller you know yeah like
get rid of the like the fun like the fun
heartfelt like good times and just make
it like dark and like something that you
think about when you leave the movie
theater for like hours yeah like it
messes
with your psyche like truly stepping
into the mindset of the other person and
discovering their emotions and the term
like really uncover the term turmoil
must be like what's in their brain
or not you can just keep it cute that's
Disney you know how they do I mean I
would take either honestly yeah
well anyway we'll transition back to
sincerity for a second here sure
um
the Chinese people that could have been
racist they handled it well well yes
yeah but they did I mean I don't know if
people would still find a racist or not
but I was like probably where are we
going with this they'd be like oh
they're in the typical role of where
Chinese people don't understand things
and they just like fortune cookies
fortune cookies to like make them yes
people are going to be like this is out
of touch but
um they were both very funny great
actresses I like seeing older movies in
the lens of how today would find things
problems it would go absolutely not when
I watch it and I'm like I have no issues
with anything of what they did here even
Chad Michael Murray and his creepiness
I'm just like it's just amusing to me
just a movie the Chinese stuff I'm like
it's amusing it's uh they can't really
do that now but I would love I love I
love when like movies like this get
discovered on Twitter today
I don't know how dare they people like
lose it
I'm like well it was fun I had fun
watching even the cliche of how they of
how uh therapy has been viewed so much
in in film through so much of so much of
the years of like only only like truly
troubling crazy distraught people
yeah absolutely and it's it's really
just like normal people day to day who
are like I need somebody to talk to when
really this is just a comedy from a
couple decades ago I'm just preparing
for you know how some people are going
to view it yeah I wonder I wonder if it
has had any type of turn like that but
it is kind of fun to see to pick and
choose which films are now problematic
it has this hasn't happened with Freaky
Friday yet I just think it's funny that
I could totally see a scenario where it
could happen one day well yeah if
they've replayed the same games in the
in the new ones which they're not gonna
do that you should do it exactly the
same make them even more Chinese like
more Chinese stereotypes that would be
hilarious
this this lived up to what I wanted to
be and it had more and had more emotion
than I actually anticipated expected
yeah I thought it was just going to be
corny like campy comedy uh and it
actually had a lot of heart like the
ending I was like uh award-winning
performances here I believe both of them
so much dropped into those characters
and like it was just great I I was there
with them and they made me feel and I
like that and other than the
exceptionally wild understanding and
forgiveness that the fiance Ryan has
right other than that I still really
appreciate it because at the end of the
day it's certain kind of moving you got
a certain kind of tone that allows you
to get away with certain kind of things
certain kind of behaviors like that I
still really appreciate his height into
the switch bodies so with Ryan of how
they did turn him into
like he evolved as a character
throughout it and and his intentions and
what like what he really wanted out of
this relationship how that came to light
and how he helped motivate the not only
his relationship with Jamie Lee Curtis
but also
um proxy helping to change his
relationship with the daughter yeah I
thought was really well done I thought
it was a great handling and like how you
brought the scene with the brother in in
the parent-teacher conference yeah of
giving like a deeper understanding like
what's going on underneath the surface
of these characters so for a movie that
has her your your uh your your lead
character as a psychologist it is fun to
see a movie that does explore with like
our four characters what's going on
underneath the service and even with
Chad Michael Murray at first going oh
let's not judge this guy we're off the
bat is just some like cool Rebel on a
bike right he's actually a really like a
guy looking for love so much so that he
will he can get very toxic and dangerous
apparently
[Music]
so desperate for love
is there something seriously off about
him in this room a little bit
yeah it's creepy I also
and how they frame it though like in the
movie you just like totally accept that
like the next day he's just fine and
likes Anna even though he has no idea
that they switch bodies like yeah I I I
find that where I'm just like oh okay
but it's a movie and you accept it
um I think it's just played for it's
played for so much romance and you're
supposed to root version you're supposed
to but you're like you just got over her
mom two seconds ago yeah you were
outside the house last night singing to
her and upset she was going to get
married trying to sabotage you you
crashed the rehearsal right like that
that's a pretty intense thing I would
have liked it more if it was a flip of
like he is now distraught and he's like
I'll I'll I like you but I'll I'll
always love your mom and he like rides
off on the Ducati and no one's ever seen
him again that would be uh preferred in
my opinion and then she just is like
Anna's there and she dances with her
little brother oh yeah that would be
sweet because now she would no no she
wouldn't know would she know she does
know about the letter and then maybe he
swoops in because Grandpa's like go to
this I go to dance but then the Santa
comes in she's like Hey kid like you
want to dance and then they dance and
that's sweet and then forget about
Ducati guy because he's kind of nice
fell in love with Mom and now brother
and sister we see it again that they are
now gonna have a better relationship
because he because of the letter that's
a good and you're welcome I mean stick
me in the writer's room and call it a
day kid would have brought it back
around to that storyline too that's not
bad Tara that's not bad not bad you're
an inventive human being thank you so
much creative yeah I hope our comments
about Chad Michael Murray's character
overshadow everyone first going wow I
really love Greg and Tara's reaction
and then they're like no how dare you
make fun of her make fun of Chad the
very obviously creepy guy
he just shouldn't have ended up with her
I think at the end like you were in love
with her mom two seconds ago yeah
there's like no he's being tossed I'm
like why are you so in love like why are
you like so if you look at the Timeline
guys he had just met properly Anna
Thursday yeah
Thursday yeah right it was very even
Thursday yes and then Friday he's just
like hunting them down and the next day
he's like I love you now Anna also how
did he not get fired from serving her
coffee and then he just sat down during
his place of work and nobody was like
hey buddy get back to work I'm like that
was that could have been a little bit of
a goal like comedy Gold Line where
someone's like hey man what are you
doing like yeah you're supposed to be we
got a line back here and he's a senior
and I'm assuming no yeah I don't think
he's a senior he just like works there
right
because see I was confused when he's
like I just work here and I'm like he
had a teacher's key you don't give that
to students right or unless he's a
senior that also works there
I don't know it's complicated they
should have explained we gotta look at
look everything that we're supposed to
love about this movie we love we love I
love I I this is a lot of fun I love
this movie I thought it was great it's
great there's just a lot of questions
about Chad Michael Murphy that I'm like
he yeah he yeah yeah questions I can't
even get all the words out uh I typed in
Chad Michael Moran Wikipedia what I
meant to type in freaking what is he up
to now damn he is a handsome guy though
he is a very attractive I mean if
there's some guy who you can accept for
being a uh not a 2003 okay
all right let's uh are they gonna like
okay we're gonna try to learn about this
all right okay is it earthquake Blah
Blah Blah Talk Show psychology like
where's his name he's not in here he's
not they they removed him from the
Wikipedia
okay let's look up his character name
and then we're gonna they don't have
like a list of characters well they
might we're gonna put it at the bottom
at the bottom of that paragraph yeah
okay his name is
is Jake all right let's type in Jake
here
okay Jake knows his ass
okay and now we're ready to watch the
interview on television doesn't say what
he does
he loses his enamoration towards Anna
after she sabotages Stacy's test okay we
gotta see if there's anyone else on the
internet that has thought
Jake is it Freaky Friday is crazy is it
still one of them is a student
she's a student because we would love to
know
um 18 or 19 and he does ACT immature so
it makes he does he didn't though okay
it's not made clear what is the age
difference she's 15 he works at her
school so this has been see this has
been oh my God we have been stuck on
he's obsessed and we haven't we've
barely even scratched the surface on how
old is this guy actually I guarantee you
there is a Reddit Forum that just
discusses all of this yeah there's a lot
of people okay he wasn't just an older
guy at school he worked for the school
which is why he had access and they're
like that's weird people are saying it's
weird
okay yeah we're not the only ones who
thought the only ones people think it's
weird it is weird like how are you stop
hitting on high school students if you
work there how old are you sir that's
true I assume he was just like 19 like
it wasn't that crazy but still I'm like
what's I mean
15 and 19 is a that's a big difference
yeah she wasn't like a senior yeah
you're right I mean just get out of here
kid stop hitting on the girls at school
yeah it's crazy you work there bring him
back in the sequel and acknowledge all
this put him in jail
lock him up that's what the sequel
should be about Jake in jail
so
jail oh man there's a lot of it like
he's someone's and he body swapped
through that person to jail that would
be great no because then you have to
like then you're like in jail there's no
campy fun comedy really in jail I think
you can make something that is totally
confusing yeah where you're like I don't
know if I should be laughing at this
right or right or crying laughing or
crying that's a good place to put an
audience in right where they're like I'm
not sure on the edge of my seat should I
have brought my children
or a box of tissues we don't know but uh
yeah Lindsay that's great she's so good
in that scene I'm like dang all right
Lindsay I believe she's great they're
both so good in this she's a great
actress it's like crazy how
yeah it's I think that it's crazy how
much she like missed out on continuing
to act I know she had a recent like
Netflix Christmas movie I didn't watch
it sorry I heard it's good uh okay it's
good that I'm like oh maybe she's like
back in the back in the swing of things
she just was gone for so long and she is
she is great I get how it would be hard
being a child actress because
The Parent Trap popped up and I'm like
she looks five and I don't think I've
seen that movie so that means she's been
acting forever oh yeah no I think it's
it you have I think you have to really
protect a child actor who becomes famous
yeah every skill stranger things I have
been Gravely concerned about oh yeah
uh yeah you have to really protect it
growing up in the spotlight like that I
just it's tough It's really really that
that's that is hard and it's so
isolating too in the sense of
a lot of people would assume like well
no they're the kid with the greatest
life they get the fame and the fortune
at such a young age and so that it's
even more it's easier to be
misunderstood and you also have a harder
time adapting to real life and
understanding people's motives and what
they might want from you and you know
like there's so many terrible things
that I could imagine creates this
Snowball Effect oh yeah um so yeah I I I
I totally sympathize and you're not as
well equipped at that age to deal with
like the emotional
um
sort of torture of like feedback on you
and your career on the choices that
you've made and are you a good actor or
not like that's a lot for a kid to
handle because emotionally you're not
and your brain is not fully equipped
either and then when you're a child the
actor especially you know now we try to
embrace like oh look how real they are
on social media there's only a certain
extent people can be real on social
media right yeah when you're a child
actor they really like freaking program
you to how to behave around people in
total uh and Beyond just how you are on
set like they really program you on that
like that's one of the cliches of like
stage Moms come from and how to be
around casting directors and adults and
how to present yourself in public and
and all these things like yeah adults
get that with publicist but it's
different when you're learning to
navigate it then when you're a kid it's
like you feel like you always have to be
a certain way so you're always kind of
handled yeah but here she felt like such
a real teenager you know yeah like if it
felt so it felt so real and and I
respected it a lot and Jamie Lee Curt is
um because I thought at the beginning I
really think like Jamie Lee Curtis like
I mean she's Jamie Lee Curtis one of the
best actresses of all time like right
off the bat she just nailed the switch
the bottom switch like just all of her
nuances so good because they actually
played it really felt like they were
making the the effort to play the
characters versus
you know let me just play this like a 15
year old have you seen Shazam Fury of
the Gods no the latest is that the
latest no because I got a little upset
about his mentee breakdown
um about John Wick 4 and not telling
people not to go see it and I was like
sir you really need to calm down and now
I'm not gonna see Shazam for a while
even though I loved the first one I'll
see it I think it was slightly edited
the way that went down but now he's kind
of a social media like like
it was like John Wick four don't go see
that see Suzanne I haven't seen the full
clip oh my gosh sir I've never
accomplished on it because I don't know
what the full clip of the context is it
was just kind of a lot and I was like
listen I think that the worst thing to
do to promote your movie the week before
is not to throw another movie under the
bus and tell people Shazam is a
family-friendly movie John Wick is not
gonna be that it's just like and it's a
far better movie I swear to you he said
he either said far better or and it's a
better movie and I'm like
you did say it's a better movie I was
losing my mind because uh number one I'm
like I don't even know if he's seen it
and number two you're wearing a mental
breakdown by trying to get people to go
see your film by throwing another film
under the bus I don't enjoy any of this
he probably went through it had a mental
breakdown okay I get it you were losing
it and that's probably not you as a
person I enjoy it because you know how I
feel about John Wick I I think though
that you know sometimes it is important
in order to elevate yourself you got to
throw under other people under the bus
yep John Humphrey's a big piece of
guys you've got to build your pedestal
by walking on top of other people if you
make other people look less than it
makes you look better that's how you
elevate yourself this whole thing about
like if you try to elevate other people
elevates you
no I could have really learned from that
video then is what you're saying I got
mad about it Shazam Fury the gods made a
lot of money
anyway I brought up that movie because
um one of the criticisms do you know the
general concept of Shazam of how he says
Shazam and he's a big boy's body big
guy's body yes yeah so the one of the
criticisms that's really been levied at
it his name's Zach Levy haha that's
funny
um that's been levied at it is that
um it doesn't seem like there's any real
melding of the of the two personalities
of young boy Billy and old boy Billy
that he's just like I'm playing a 15
year old doofus and then in a grown
man's body like it feels like a
completely different person and that is
not the case here like Jamie Lee Curtis
really captured that youth but really
captured what Lindsay Lohan was going
for and still making it her own as well
without relying too much on an imitation
and I and she she nailed that right off
the bat and I felt Lindsay Lohan
um found her way into that as the movie
went in a much smoother way it's the
point where I was like oh now I really
believe her so especially if they sent
each other like like lines
I would be like send me all the lines I
do not mind getting like a line read and
I'll make some of them my own but if you
can get a taste of like how she would
say it then you I feel like if they did
that it's very smart because then you
could really drop into the character if
you're you're hearing it you're able to
like repeat it and go like okay I feel
like now I'm in Lindsay Lauren's body or
by vice versa
um do people say vice versa or vice
versa vice versa yeah I heard someone
the other day maybe they said that or
said a different thing I'm like maybe
I've been saying it wrong the whole time
did they send each other
tapes I mean now that I type it in it's
going to be a bunch of articles about
God freaking we don't have time I know
hold on let me try one more search Amy
Lee Curtis freaky Sprite sending like
did they like Jimmy's and Curtis sending
Lindsay Lohan like my recording lines
Freaky Friday
I was saying recorded lines for each
other okay
talk Freaky Friday come on touch for a
sequel which Disney sizes and it works
already written to Disney everything's
about the sequel
stressing me really just like did they
you know what we could do we could just
look it up if it's a fact on IMDb
um
is pro it's probably a a fun fact on
IMDb
oh yes okay
let me
now let's just sift through these 335
facts quiet Tara
great ideas you don't even know where to
find it where do you find it doesn't
even know where to find you fit on IMDb
do you know where they're located okay
wait do I they're like down hold on
there's like somewhere here somewhere
down see did you know and you go yeah
right here did you know trivia which
asked what do you
um
uh your prompt okay
that's funny originally I did okay blah
blah blah Jody Foster he's a Jody
Foster as I almost did them for Pope
Francis another character or okay
had six days to prepare for the role of
Tess damn after net Benning dropped out
wow
that's insane great job
um
okay maybe I made that up
I really thought I really thought that
was a truth I don't know why
I thought that I don't see anything
about it there's nothing here
maybe I was wrong
you guys let us know in the comments
maybe they did we just didn't find it
what do you think about Freaky Friday
leave your thoughts down below do you
think Chad Michael Murray is creepy in
this yeah let us know I certainly think
so
hey let's do a patron of the day shout
out Michael B Omni media he's got a
really great reaction Channel closing in
on 50 000 subscribers well well well
Michael B I would love to body swap with
you for a day so that way you can
experience what it's like to run real
rejects it's tough and then I would
experience what it's like to run your
Channel
and then watch as I take it to
surpassing the real Rejects and
subscribers wow in one whole day one day
showing my skills okay as someone who
reacts to stuff
and what I'm capable of doing and
instilling I would literally save every
aspect of your channel he's literally
going to be sitting in the corner
drinking energy drinks crying over the
editing yeah
in the dark and I'll be like these views
because this channel has not been around
as long is not getting as many views as
I'm used to getting and now I'm stressed
out Michael he's gonna have to see two
therapists now and then watch what I
would love to happen is then you're me
on the channel
and then people are like hey Greg's
different I love this new version of
Greg they love the new they love the new
Greg a lot whatever you've turned into
Greg we love it amazing
um I
I would I could there I want people to
be like wow I unsubscribed because I
couldn't stand Greg anymore right but
but then you get news because the new
Greg is wrong and then those subscribers
who unsubscribe they go they return oh
they return because new Greg is more
enjoyable they like the yeah so they
leave and they all come back so you're
you're basically at square square one
yeah you're good okay and then my goal
to grow your channel actually tanks and
uh loses 20 000 subscribers so real
rejects is still standing presents us
better than ever with new Greg because
Michael is being Greg yeah Greg Bean
Michael has caused Channel his channel
his channel it's to plummet and Michael
just he I guess after the Freaky Friday
Michael won't have the channel anymore
yeah but the real the old real rejects
will still be pumping them out huh yeah
the new Greg yeah
okay I don't like this idea it's hurting
my ego is it yeah okay like I said you
gotta tear the people down to lift
yourself up sure yeah I mean we all knew
you you needed a little help it's like
Greg is Greg right now he's like he's
fine yeah he could be a little bit
better right a little like
there's there's people that are they're
agreeing right now like you're he's I
feel the stairs and I am going there's
people back there going yep she's right
there with me trust me just like
be just like sitting it you know what I
mean see what you've done you have
elevated yourself
tearing me down so that's why I feel so
good right now how everyone's like I
love Tara more yeah she's a better
person and she knows more things
absolutely
feel great
patron of the day Shout
[Music]